good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the sunset Safari here on Sunday
afternoon I think it's a Sunday
afternoon anybody you're looking at a
leopard believe it or not that is husana
the male leopard my name is James Henry
this is my Sunday smile and you have got
since autumn Keys on camera there those
is three fingers he only has three
fingers otherwise he'd show you the
others he does remarkable job for a
three fingered man
well done since we are not learning out
here ralph Kirsten is tracking lions on
foot if you can believe it a brave thing
to do on a Sunday afternoon o par is
using the grinder in the workshop you
might be able to hear that wonderful
sounds for Sunday afternoon the
wilderness and 15 we have Sydney heading
out towards Tandy and her cub at sunset
please talk to us using the hash tags
for a live on track otherwise you may
use the chat stream on YouTube to ask us
questions send us your comments you may
insult us if you wish to can't promise
that I'll acknowledge your insults but
you can certainly try and send us your
amusing anecdotes that would also be
quite good ok
the reason you can hear the angle
grinder if you can hear the angle blind
is that we're very close to camp and
that's because Hosanna has been hanging
around very close to camp let's go a
little bit closer to him I'm gonna try
and spend some time with special cat
oops
come on Wendy there we go that's my girl
yeah
Amy yes it is a beautiful Sunday
afternoon Wendy would disagree with you
that is the vehicle I'm driving
she has stalled luckily we're on a hill
as long as her sonamoo sometime during
the day we'll be able to put her out
he's gently up towards the water
hopefully get a better view
hello kitty how are you it's very nice
to see you it's heads up which is a well
somewhat unusual for the last little
while spent a lot of time with his head
down and if you are perhaps a new viewer
this is horse Anna the male leopard aged
two and a half and he disappeared about
three or four months ago he went off
searching his independence having to do
that with my lipids doing he's wandered
back here to his sort of home town if
you like for a little while I don't
think he's going to be here for very
long because generally they aren't
yes k-6 is fast becoming that way isn't
that husana spends an inordinate amount
of time with this pan I'd be very happy
to call this horse on a pan now you just
keep your head up boy there were some
Yala here I tried to get them and him in
the same picture but they saw him and
made their barking noises and then
wandered off decided they didn't want to
be around him any longer
I'm going to spend an extended period
with horse owner today see what he gets
up to he's had a very successful time at
this pan he's killed a duiker
he's killed an Impala somewhere around
here as well stash them both in the same
tree given us some magnificent pictures
of him in his tree attracted his father
his father then well either stole asked
him for and was granted a piece of his
supper she looks very content indeed oh
yes you just go back in there hmm are
you tired poor little fellow
Oh shame and dose as they say enough for
cards which means sleep I can't promise
you a great deal of action from Hassan
of this afternoon I might not be with
him more afternoon but we're going to
spend quite a lot of time with him then
he luck will have three cats or three
cat sightings here before the day is up
as I say Ralph is trying to find some
lions and I've been magnificent if we
had them too we might go and help him
out in the vehicle if he finds him on
foot and Sydney heading towards the
magical magical Tandy and her baby all
righty let's head across to Ralphy find
out how far he's got towards the unknown
pride from earlier well good afternoon
everybody and welcome aboard once again
with the bush walk and the sunset safari
my name is Ralph Kirsten on the camera
you've got Craig today how's it Craig
okay a Batman and hello once again to
all of you now please don't forget to
send us your questions and your comments
on the hashtag Safari lava on Twitter
and on the YouTube live chat because
we'd love to know what you want to know
about the African bush now we're coming
to you live from the juma Traverse in
the greater Kruger National Park of
Africa and I'm heading towards the unco
Houmas where they those of the lion
pride that was spotted this morning
right up in our eastern corner so we're
gonna be hitting in that direction
because I went after the sunrise Safari
and I tried to catch up with him again
but it seemed like they might have moved
so we're just gonna go and check if we
can't find the tracks and just find him
a little bit again this afternoon with
this kind of heat to be having it's
rather warm it's warmed up from the last
few days so I think it's every chance
that these lines will be lying up in the
shade as lions do a little bit more
lethargic than lipids might be when it
gets warm like this and with there being
a nice big group of them it should be
quite easy for us to find their tracks
so that's exactly what we're going to be
looking for and Rickson game scout he's
scouting out as per usual and trying to
get these little tracks now Joe thanks
for your question I hear that the
birmingham's
they've hit it quite a lot further south
down towards London Losey or into the
area a little bit further south in the
sabi sands so it doesn't seem like there
anyway in the area and it looks like the
Avoca miles have now every opportunity
to really stake their claim as the
territorial males of the area and with
the Oklahoma Cubs there were three
little tiny little balls of fluff that
we received news of that have been
killed by hyenas so as sad as that mark
that is they still now every chance that
the overt camels are going to relax with
the young kuma pride and possibly mic'd
within and then have their own cubs so
it actually might be better for the
coomer's in the long run because they're
not gonna be having the space like they
have been having when they killed it
but falaya near vodkas coming in and
chasing them off and really splitting
them up and then we had those two
youngsters that were literally roaming
the property looking for their family
for a few days so that might all calm
down if the Volkers actually cover some
of these females and get some cubs of
their own so it's not such a bad thing
in the long run as I say with those
double cuts having been killed so
sometimes that's the way the wild works
a little bit of a sacrifice for some can
make things a little bit better now
we're gonna get hot on the trail and
while we're doing that I'm gonna hit you
back to James was elated
well look he's changed direction so we
too have changed direction here what is
the gorgeous winter's afternoon I will
tell you unfortunately that Wendy is
having inordinate amounts of trouble
there right front tires gone flat she's
struggling to start sir I'm not sure how
long we're going to be exactly where we
are but hopefully you know well Sydney
we'll get going soon he's having some
troubles as well back if camp it all
seems to happen at once
well sauna enjoying very much being out
on a Sunday afternoon
lexy we don't know where tin Ghana's
gone Tristan heard him calling at about
10 o'clock last night what a long way
south of where we are now so he's
probably just followed the Umrah might
see drainage they will river down
towards the southern parts of jummah he
probably got tired halfway and went
asleep for an extended period he likes
to do that so he's probably not too far
away actually
but see it's very tired now much smaller
than his father stole his father's a
heavyset fellow at the moment has been
well really doing well off the scraps of
others I'm gonna ask you to swing the
camera around sends alt because what we
have there is a fairly rare event you
see there down through that gap
there's the niala ball and Anala cow
it's not a rare event as an event we
don't often see it looked like there may
have been about to get it on as it were
now of course they're on screen and so
their bit nervous and try but normally
you don't see it or you very seldom see
it with the antelope because they're a
very quick event of mating is what I'm
talking about here and can some of your
confused I doubt you will be but that is
what I'm on about and well Hasan is
pretty well hidden where he is and if
something does come down to have a drink
on this warmish afternoon you can rest
assured that he is going to hide from
them and then try and jump on them as
they have a quiet Sunday drink which is
a I think an unfortunate thing to
experience on the Sunday afternoon
Jennifer you say it looks exactly like
Tenggara well if you say so I personally
do not I cannot see the resemblance
between leopards that oh well that's not
true actually
I I'm not very good at discerning one
leopard from the other but I perfectly
accept that many people are and I've
certainly seen evidence of it so if you
say it looks like Tenggara take your
word for it
I am I ever going to ask you if you have
ever you'd also described in Ghana as
beautiful and I'm going to ask you if
you have ever described a leopard as
ugly because I suspect you have not
I think they're all pretty magnificent I
made the mistake of calling a leopard
pug faced once and I was soundly
chastised by various members of the
Twitterverse but they are of course all
beautiful something has set a whole lot
of birds to flight is there a raptor
above us perhaps no I don't see a raptor
yeah there wasn't asana he didn't move
at all
there is the sunday sky not bad for
winter is it and gets about 27 degrees
out here which was roughly 79 or 80
degrees Fahrenheit
mmm that's an interesting one Koster
cooked in Ghana v tolerating husana
because he provides food um no I don't
think so
I think he's tolerating him simply
because he's his son and I don't know
how to explain that better you know easy
it's it's not like he's not behaving in
a completely under a toriel manner I
believe he was sent marking the other
day although whether he was sent marking
actually for real or just sort of
relieving himself is unclear so I'm not
really sure but I don't you know I don't
think that makes a huge difference I
think if he started to sort of mate with
some of the females in this area which
would have to be his will his sister's
basically sister and his oh gosh was
difficult to figure it out um Tommy is
his sister and therefore kochava is his
aunt well his his cousin no his niece
it'd have to be his niece or his sister
which from her deal was impossible for
it to work with the other cats but isn't
ideal now you know I think he started to
try and mate then maybe to Ghana
wouldn't be quite so tolerant of him but
at the moment he is he is tolerant and
you can see just left him he's gone off
marking his territory it hasn't felt the
need to hang around here and make sure
that he keeps an eye on husana he's just
left him
ah marvelous Sydney has managed to fix
his technical difficulties he is out on
drive I'm not going to get in try and
fix mine a very very good afternoon to
you all my name is Sydney and welcome to
the beginning of the game drive I am NOT
suffering alone this afternoon I have
got figures
he is my camera operator our plan for
this afternoon is quite very much easy
earlier on there's been quite a lot of
different cat sightings and I have
decided this afternoon to go and see
Tandy and calamba I will be going toward
the central side of the game reserve
where I'm hoping to have a very good
sighting and for your questions and
comments you can follow us on twitter
hashtag Safari Live and also on YouTube
chat stream without any waste of time I
am now going to head towards the central
area of the game reserve in order to see
if we can find Tandy and Columba
Sophia the lions and leopards if you can
check the lions are very much more
active and in the mornings and their
tracks are way much bigger than the
leopard tracks lepers during the day yes
they're nocturnal but you will see them
doing some of the activities during the
day with the attracts much smaller
compared to the Lion tracks and the
Lions they are they are quite easy to
track than the lepers lepers can be so
very shy and they can easily come off
late so lions is easy to track them yes
they can come off let you the grasses
but they look much bigger and they
normally walk in big prize
so I am very happy with this kind of
weather this afternoon as I can see that
is very sunny and there's no too much
cold so the chances of animal activities
are really are very day
so I will be approaching the central
part of the game Reserve coming from the
eastern side of the game Reserve which
is a little bit much more towards the
Kruger National Park
Orson I didn't copy your question very
well F see if he can repeat that
question for me the hippie was they
don't really fight for the food because
he's too much yes he was a consisted of
different group of animals which have
got quite a lot of different preferences
some of these herbivores are bulk
grazers whereby when it comes to feeding
they are not selective they just feed on
both grass and leaves whereas some they
only eat leaves and some only eat grass
so this he was there he was but they
fall into different categories
so now I will be driving down let's see
if my colleagues on the other side are
having something already well we haven't
found the Inca humans just yet everybody
that we're still making ground obviously
on foot we don't move as fast as we are
with the vehicles but looking at this
little track that we found while we are
that just giving you a nice scale of how
big it is and let's just have a chick
and exactly the length of it as well
with my trusty live them in there so
we're looking at what is that it's about
looking at about five five inches what
is that scale they're centimetres we're
looking at about eight centimeters
between seven and eight centimeters
there on this check what you can also
notice is on each tile with where we can
see two flat tiles there in each tile
very very flat footed or flat tiled if I
can say that and also it looks like it's
direct registered once again and down
the middle you can see a very very faint
Lani so these tiles are very tightly
pressed up against one another and so it
does make quite a characteristic track
now Rhonda you say that's shaped like a
heart
it is indeed but yeah just a little bit
on the outside there you can see where
the front foot is actually pressed and
then the back foot having come and
stepped right on the inside of it so
that gives us a good indication that it
is one of the trailer fiends or the
spiral Horned antelope and when we're
looking at this kind of size we would be
thinking between niala and coudl so that
would be what we're going for there and
another thing that we do want to just
have a look at is where is the widest
part of the track and this one coming up
a little bit towards the back so about
three-quarters of the way the widest
part being about there
before it starts curling again on the
inside so the twin Yala and kudu and I
would have to definitely say that I
think that this is more so than a female
kudu check and because just of the way
that it's so pressed was so tight
between the toes like that making that
very clear little Ridge there between
the toes but a nice characteristic track
between y'all and kudu very difficult to
tell between them now just to look at a
very clear-cut difference it's nice hard
substrate yeah so um we just put the the
same live them in here we've got a check
but it's almost like we can only see the
outside of it there and very indicative
of of an Impala track we said that they
walk on the rims or on the edges of the
toes there and there so this is an
Impala check and they do not direct
register they're not one of the tackler
fiends
so quite easy to distinguish an Impala
track as well
now it's also something a little check
over here
now Robin you say carrying a little moon
is genius well I never leave home
without it Robin so yes I would say it's
genius but it almost goes without saying
for me nowadays and I never leave home
as I say with artists now looking at
this little track I left they actually
get something smaller because my stick
is almost too big here we can see a
little back pad over there and then
we've got a toe there well another one
there another one there and another one
there and on this back pad here we can
see that it's slightly lopsided like
that and possibly even something over
there as well this is that of a little
dwarf
mungus so very very nice and there's
lots of little tracks along here you
just have to look very closely and so
from our eyes down on the ground let's
put your eyes up into the trees
quite a very beautiful small animal this
critter is busy trying to have a little
bit of diet is right on top of the
rusted bush willow
so the squealers are one of the very
clever small mammals they don't have
been ate during the winter season simply
because they can be able to collect
quite a lot of food they catch and they
also take quite a lot of nuts and they
hide them somewhere here in between the
trees and also on the ground this
animals have got a very interesting
anti-theft precaution whereby they are
going to dig quite a lot of false holes
just to mislead they on Lucas when they
are hiding and they bury and reburied
their food every time they've got good
memory because if he's going to bury
something by a prayer this year in order
to use it now during the winter season
you can see that they must have to be
having a good memory so they also
secrete some of the scent in order to
remember where they are hiding the food
so I've got to take some questions now
from the FC I didn't copy nicely the the
name of the viewer who just asked me now
a question about my favorite sightings
since I have joined the wild ft Murphy
my favorite sighting since I've joined
Juma well death team is the day I saw
the Lions together with a ton d chasing
each other right by Central Road in the
middle of the game reserve that has been
my best sighting because that day it was
punctuated with cats chasing each other
lions chasing leppas three lepers also
appeared two lepers were also fighting
it was very much interesting to see
those kind of activities and I never saw
it happening before is only here in
Douma where I got the chance yeah so now
the squirrel just got disappeared and I
will be now heading to Central and see
what is happening there and thank you
very much Murphy for such a lovely
question that sighting is good memories
to me
yeah so now I will be heading towards
the eastern side of the game Reserve and
see what we can find
Tandi is quite a little bit far away
from where I am at this stage so maybe
before we get there we might come across
other interesting things on the road I
haven't seen yet any of the big animals
here
maybe animals are now down at the
waterhole
definitely they African wild cats the
size of the track is quite very small
but if you look at it nicely it does
resemble this they the shape of the big
cats it has got the three antelope the
three loops as well similar like the big
cats so it's not that very big and it
does confuse when thinking about animals
such as the vets so it means if I find
it I've got to look very carefully
before I come up with the judgment
not even an Impala here so it's quite
hot today
and then animals in order to avoid this
kind of temperature some they go and
find some nice shade and and choose some
card and some of them they have got to
go to the waterhole so since I've
started I haven't seen any of the
antelopes
yeah so now when I'm going towards Tandy
let's hear if Ralph my colleague on the
other side got something already
everyone we've just managed to find
something very exciting now what I want
you to do is just look through those
branches of the day and you're gonna see
the animal that we have been tracking
and just a little bit from this morning
and just a little bit further into the
quarry's but not too far and this looks
like a young male just what she looks
like it a bit of a sneeze there yep
another one how is that walking Lions on
foot and I can tell you what there's
another one up too in the background as
well just gone off and going to lay in
the shade maybe it's getting a bit hot
but I can tell you what I can tell you
what it's one of the most amazing things
to walk irons on foot and it's normally
a little bit of an anti-climax actually
because I can tell you if are to go
towards these lines have probably just
get up and run away from us so it's not
that we're terribly concerned to be in
such close proximity you can see the
more the concern coming from the Lions
watching us but we've got nice brush
between us and him so nothing for either
of us to worry about and we'd always
just watch their body language in terms
of how relaxed they are with us if they
had a nice big you own as well
now grateful bed you say I must walk
softly and carry a big stick
I've got a little stick with me and I
will walk softly as well but we've been
doing this for years
it's absolutely fast and I think I still
love it I still enjoyed every single
time I do it and it just makes me proud
to be African and just be with these
guys
foot
Oh welcome welcome to all the viewers
now we are coming to you live from the
juma Traverse in the greater Kruger
National Park of South Africa
you're watching Safari live my name is
Ralph Kirsten and we've we've just
walked in on a pride of lions on foot
and you can see very relaxed at the
moment just carrying on with their
business and well we've come in with the
Sun over our shoulders with the wind and
how into our face and now you can see
that the line obviously and just moving
a little bit away from us but it might
also be as a result of the Sun being
quite warm today and the Lions will
generally seek a little bit of shade at
the moment you see it's not running away
so it's not like he's terribly concerned
about us being here
look it's just gonna be joining the rest
of the prod going and lying down in the
shade there this being the kuruma prod
they also will just be probably about
five females or maybe six youngsters now
Martina you say hello mama Lyons I'm
just going a little bit closer that will
keep this brush between us and Lim just
to make sure that they are nice and
comfortable and also that we have a bit
of a safe sign as well so we won't be
going any further than this point here
because we've got lovely ground between
us and them
and that we don't want to disturb them
and we obviously don't want to put
ourselves in danger either now Patrick
from Toronto welcome welcome I hope that
you can enjoy with us a little bit of a
feeling of Africa that this really makes
me proud to be South African and African
at large because well where else could
you walk lines on like this on foot
totally wild totally free these lines
are really in their natural habitat it's
quite difficult through there into the
brush to see them very clearly now but
it's not as easy to get in close
proximity with lions on foot as it might
be with the vehicle there are a lot more
relaxed
with a vehicle now Michelle you you're
asking if you think that this yes
Michelle they not only see us today they
hear me now talking as well you can see
some of the tails flicking away but this
is absolutely no sort of aggressive
signs towards us actually stressed
couple of little eyes just watching us
but we've got the wind in our face and
the Sun over our shoulder so now
obviously struggling a little bit to see
us in fine detail but they definitely
know that we here but with us keeping
this bit of brush and and very clear
vegetation between us and them if we had
to break this then they might get up and
run away either that or they could
charge us so it would normally be a
fight or flight but mostly flat Carolyn
you said that we're very lucky
absolutely I agree with you and and well
I think that every day when I'm out here
walking amongst elephants and lions and
leopards and Buffalo it is absolutely
fascinating now there were some Buffalo
around earlier that it seems like these
whom Kuma's were following but they seem
to have moved off now prashant you're
asking why we call them the the king of
the jungle when when they actually live
in the Savannah in the bush well I think
they just use jungle as a as a term like
we do here in South Africa as as a term
before the wilderness so I would say
that it's just the king of the
wilderness but also remember that lions
used to be one of the most wildly we
spread cats of all they used to find him
in Britain and in Asia and even in
Russia but they have all been killed in
all of those places that's why it's the
British lions and they have that as a
symbol for many different of the
sporting teams etc so they used to be
there but they obviously now Ryusei that
the camouflage game is very strong
absolutely look at that you do need to
have a
very trained eye and enabling you to see
them and it takes a lot of practice and
while if you keep on joining us here on
safari live you'll also get to practice
with us so I'm just gonna say goodbye to
all the viewers on the different
platforms and please join us once again
for another Safari live
okay so just welcome back to all the
regular viewers that was just a quick
action broadcast obviously very exciting
for us just to come in here with these
lines on foot it's always special and
always worth documenting so if any of
you want to send that little clip on
over to your friends you will find it on
the safari live Facebook page
and so nice to just send as little
action broadcasts as we say but not too
much action at the moment lots of
sleeping as lions do in the middle of
the day and I do believe that it's
pretty much what they're going to be
doing for the rest of the day now at
least James has got his vehicle fixed on
up so let's hear a the team I've got my
vehicle fixed and I've got a little -
the same repaired we started the show
now let us not become blasé about having
a leopard lying on our doorstep this is
not something that is going to last
forever
it's I don't know how long it's going to
last I hope it's going to last for at
least until the beginning of our TV show
on the 27th of July
that's Friday evening next for you lot
in the United States NatGeo wild 11
o'clock Eastern Time p.m. that is it
will be about 5:00 in the morning here
in on Saturday and then for the next
five weeks after that we will be doing a
one-hour TV show from the Mara and from
Juma very exciting
and we're hoping very much that that cat
you can see they're sleeping like a
celebrity he's going to be the celebrity
of the show
I don't know Sharon what's wrong with
his right lip is he got an injury there
I'm afraid I haven't spent any time with
him over the last few days if he does
have a cut or something on the top lip
or bottom lip it'll probably be from his
father giving him a SWOT yeah let's wait
for him to stick his head out but uh I
don't know about any injury there now
distressingly I'm not sure how
distressing it is but it sounds like
Sydney's father scavenger which possibly
means that Andy has moved
I have got a very interesting sighting
here I have been led by the hyena hyena
led me to a caucus and soon as the Hynek
got to the tree
a leopard stood up and come back to
defend their food there is the hina now
moving towards this direction of the
reserve which is the western side but
just up there so how I saw where the
caucus is it was very interesting
because the hina came closer stopped and
he was sniffing from the air and it was
sniffing the air particles coming from
the direction where the food is kept by
the leopard you can see now we have got
a ton d there she was not there when we
got there she came soon as the Hynek got
close to the tree
yeah this is quite a very beautiful
sighting I didn't see where the hyena
could disappear to but now I can see
that Tandi is very much in next day I'm
just gonna try by all means and see if
we can find a Columba
so let me just try and pull a little bit
much more to this side and see if we can
have a better society
yeah from giraffe girl that is true
Tandi is not a happy girl at this stage
because she had to come and defend the
caucus I'm sure she was very relaxed she
was sleeping somewhere not very far away
from the tree because she came very
quickly but I can see the hyena is still
in the area is also very relaxed waiting
to get his chance so he's also lying
down here not very far away from where I
am you can see just the the stomach
breathing you can see the movement there
the stomach is breathing so that hyena
didn't go very far it's still very here
waiting to get a chance maybe this hyena
is hungry as well I'm not too sure if
tandy is with Columba nearby at this
stage but I will try by all means and
see if Kalama is also around here
because the us seem to gather a Lyon
yes they comment from Ivy that is very
true Tandy is not going to allow anybody
to take a chance when it comes to their
food specifically when Tony has got
Columba Colombo must have to eat you can
see she's very much relaxed now but the
focus in the eyes West is looking that
direction is way that hyena is hiding at
the moment so yes that is true the
hyenas they have just been to all over
the place trying to irritate and to try
and get hold of all the food caught by
this leopard they are just on over Juma
Game Reserve get depending on this the
kind of case that find by all means
it's just that leopards are well much
gifted they are very skilled climbers
they take their food up to a tree to
avoid competition which is a good thing
why I'm saying it's a good thing because
they don't hunt as a team so they are
very much solitary so killing an animal
for just one leopard is a big job
so they're gonna have to enjoy the
reward if someone come and take the food
afterwards to me
is not nice but that is how animals live
- because they don't catch a lot they
depend on the other ones that is how
they live nature is like that we might
not see it fair but that is how it works
look at that
so these cats can hear very well and
they can see very nicely I have got a
question from Pauline Pauline since I
have started now with this game Drive I
haven't picked up any signal of the
vultures flying around I have been
looking around here to try and get
guidance from these natural factors
because when they say kill this there's
quite a lot of things that lead us if it
was not the hyena it was gonna be very
difficult for me as well to see where
the kill is but the best at this stage
is very quiet nothing is happening
no vultures and no other big birds such
as Battaglia's I have seen the vultures
and Battaglia's on the past few days
leading us to where the carcasses are
but today is just very quiet
I can see tourneys this is growing a
that is very beautiful so much I'm very
worried because I cannot see calamba and
they have been seen together earlier so
maybe the little one is hiding somewhere
nearby
yeah let's now see if James has got a
sauna
on the other side yet bullies James does
a Sousa have a sauna and he struggled to
lose her son even I would struggle to
lose her son at this point given how
flat cat he is he has not moved one
muscle loss an inch cousin here we might
be moving his diaphragm very slowly in
up and down so he can breathe the light
is slowly softening on this beautiful
Sunday afternoon
and in case you're wondering we're off
to other game drive vehicles in the
siting oh I must just call this in sorry
um I'm just going to quickly call in the
tandy siting there since Tandy is on
site same place as this morning the lid
would read Junction drakensberg there we
go
I didn't hear nuance else calling it in
so that's important
but our cat here is are doing absolutely
nothing Gary out I don't know am I
supposed perhaps if he produces
offspring one day they may have elements
of his character certainly leopards do
seem to be genetically very different
from birth from a personality point of
view they are well they seem to be born
with a personality in much the same way
as we are and I'll have no doubt that
experience modifies and molds that
personality and they definitely do seem
to be different from the very beginning
it's not a sort of blank slate as it
were so I suspect there must be a
genetic component of that attached to
you know the cat
depending on what they take take from
their mother's or Father's I really get
it at the deputies did did they pinned
him in because I'm thinking to myself do
I know people who are angry with angry
parents you know short-tempered people
with short-tempered parents actually
just thinking of my brother um well what
short-tempered producer certainly as a
tendency to grumpiness this is the
failure am innocent of my father i of
course am never grumpy so yes I would
say that if his personality remains as
it is remember that he's still young yet
but he's not territorial livid yet and
his personality may not always be quite
as confiding but yeah you may well find
that he produces offspring that are
quite friendly and like his sister Tandy
who I find quite unfriendly magnificent
don't get me wrong before you all roll
your eyes and say how dare he said that
about our Queen I I do think she's
magnificent but I don't think she's the
friendliest cat in the world
yeah Marguerite said what you'll find is
that none of these animals sleep
anything like as soundly as we sleep
what happens is that they does but if
there's a cracking branch next to him or
there's a an unusual gust of wind or as
the snort of some potential prey animal
he will deftly hear it and you'll shoot
up there cannot afford to sleep soundly
like we do all of the sounds are taken
here right now our familiar terms so
it's not gonna worry about those I
started the car he knows what that means
if I speak loudly he knows what that
means so the only thing that's going to
make him wake up would be unfamiliar or
potentially threatening sounds or
potentially advantageous arts like the
snort of an Impala or the footfall of it
yeah hoofed animal so that is possible
the only other moles that I've seen
sleeping as soundly as human beings
Alliance because they have so little to
fear they will sleep like the dead ears
don't not twitching and I walked past
Lions there inadvertently who have not
woken up as I've gone past them they
probably don't sleep quite as hard as
human beings but they certainly do sleep
and well I don't think they hear nearly
as much as a leopard doesn't asleep for
example a cheetah you seldom see
sleeping restfully always lifting the
head looking around closing eyes a
little bit lifting the head looking
around must be absolutely exhausting I
cannot believe this was Ralph Kirsten is
still with his pride into the shade and
sitting in the quarry thickets with
these lions probably between city and 40
meters away from us now let's just
watching us and it's also and quite a
few little warthogs ruddy running around
all over the place so who knows we might
even sit out with him and with us a
little bit of a hunt Wow
how lucky would that be but I'm not
gonna jinx it he's just gonna sit and
enjoy being in the company of lions
absolutely fantastic what more could you
ask for they are indeed quite curious
with us
margarita yeah I don't think that these
lines would particularly take too much
interest in us you know in the 20 years
that I have been actively working as a
professional in the field of water and
done this many times with lions and you
generally find that they they like you
know they can go from curious to being a
little bit nervous to either getting a
little bit agitated that you're around
but I've never had the sense that they
in any way things that are any kind of
food for them so it's a it's never a
worry in the sense of the tecnique eat
us the worry is always if you go near to
lions with little Cubs or lines on a
kill or lions that are making wow look
at that must be gone very cool so those
are the three major things that you want
to avoid lions with Cubs behinds and a
kill and mating lions and I've walked in
on all three of those kind of lines and
just they're a very light large growl
and sometimes very short short bursts of
of speed you're not trying to get rid of
you that's all so they give you those
warning signs but these lines at the
moment they are very relaxed I think a
couple of these youngsters are little
bit curious about us but they do keep
their eye on us and it's it's more so
them being more cautious of us now Carol
normally in this pride
I think this 11 I think it's five
females with six youngsters and is a
mixed of females and males in May but I
haven't seen if they're all together
yeah I would assume so
so they scattered around a little bit in
that in the brush so we do need to just
keep our eyes open it we wouldn't be
flanked by they met as I say
it's not not for them to be hunting us
and they're more scared of us which is
always important as humans we like to
keep and also fear and natural fear of
us because that's pretty much our only
real security against him and it's when
these animals get habituated or or used
to people that they become more
dangerous because you can get closer to
them without them giving you a warning
and and then obviously your reaction
time is less because you're closer to
them and it's also that they're gonna be
much quicker upon you if they decide
that they don't want you around anymore
so the rule is as I said earlier always
an animal's defense is going to be far
too flat and generally I'll avoid
conflict and so they will run away using
the fort but um sometimes they can
depending on the situation and decide to
fight so you just watch the body
language but with them yawning and now
even looking like they might go back to
sleep they are definitely relaxed in our
proximity to them so I'm gonna stay here
because it's absolutely wonderful to be
in a presence of lions even though they
relaxed maybe there will be the hunting
a little bit later but seems like
Sydney's lipid is on the move I think
things are happening here on my side we
just had a little bit of noise coming
from this direction and salamba picked
up the noise and started running away
all the way up to this side and Tandy
woke up and decided to follow Colombo so
we not too sure what these two are up to
at the moment
Tandy as well it was not too sure what
he sees that Columba is trying to
respond to but we hear the noise can see
kilometer
there's a question from then the the
lepers I'm not too sure specifically of
the age but these other playing
activities a lot is taking place when
they are up to 18 month from 18 month is
when they learn a lot of things
including hunting activities so it's one
of those animals that are getting all
the knowledge from playing you can see
there now is is is playing I'm sure it's
looking for some insects there it means
they it was not anything serious Jeff
Smith would thank you very much for such
a command yes we all got cats at the
moment it's quite a very big achievement
look at that if you look at the tip of
that tail is white that white color you
are seeing there is used mostly by the
adults when they are calling the babies
the tail of this animals can tell you
the mood see they use these tails for
communication alert and the tip of the
tail has got white where the adults they
raise the fluffy has to show the little
one we are going to decide you can
easily read the mood of an animal from
the tail listen to that
quite a beautiful kids
I'm not too sure if at this stage the
Columba knows that detail can serve a
big purpose Nancy Lahaina we left it
right about 10-15 meters away from the
tree where the caucus is is held so the
hyena is still there I'm sure now the
hyena must be up sniffing looking in the
caucus it's a pity the highness cannot
be able to climb up there is quite a
very straight tree no broken branch to
support the aina to get hold of the food
you can see they can easily come a
flinched is difficult to see when it's
not moving behind us Ashley the lepers
soon as they get to 22 months from 22
months on was anything can happen
because that is when they're starting to
mature and once they get mature word is
when they start to demarcate territories
and start now to establish their own
families so the lepers they can be
together with the family between two to
three years
that is where now they are starting to
leave those kind of families interesting
to see Columba just playing going over
these broken trees SAR can see where
honey is but I'm sure honey is somewhere
not very far away giving some protection
for incase if anything can happen to
Columba cats can be very much protective
a child of the universe I didn't get the
question very nicely if FCU can give me
that question again so if the question
is about growing the lepers they can
grow and the way the fully grown ones
can weigh up to 90 kilograms
SOTA lama has got a long way to grow she
is still very much young so let me see
if I can reposition myself here so that
we can have a better society yes I'm
just gonna reverse now so that I can
give my camera operator fed us an
opportunity to give you a better
sighting so now what I'm reversing maybe
we can see what other colleagues are
having on the other side I think James
has got something interesting I have got
the crested babbit look at him
is he not magnifique a beautiful bird of
scruffiness and beautiful colors we've
left for sauna now just briefly we'll go
back to him at some stage he is of
course fast asleep and that bird is just
too magnificent for words
he's got his little Mohawk up for Sunday
he's very pleased to be safe where he is
he's very regal his try you know what
he's attempting to look regal I'm not
full that a crested bar that could ever
look particularly regal they're just a
little scruffy
yes Ally I have found Tristan's angry
bird that is correct my Angry Bird is
the bard outlet which looks very serious
and very angry all the time like the
chicken hawk it's interesting from time
to time my phone seems to think that I'm
asking it a question shut up I'm not
asking you a question between to peep
I'm sorry I don't understand what you
said
then the other thing that we have over
here other than the beautiful bird is a
somewhat macabre scene over there
therefore there are fun little birds
indeed they're one of my favorites again
they remind me of sort of the touch of
the wilderness that was allowed by the
gardens that we used to have in
Johannesburg the big city where I grew
up there is the carcass that there was
so much angst about both between father
and son and of course it attracted the
hyenas for a long time they've dropped
it into place but they will not be able
to retrieve it it's on some very II sort
of thin twigs and there's not much left
but that impala are dead thing is going
to come down from there until the tree
releases it I don't think anything's
gonna be able to get up there to to get
hold of it except maybe a gin it may be
a gin it would get hold of it'd be quite
fun to watch force on a try they
wouldn't anyway that's a bit miserable
let's carry on
oh no it's not unfortunately the poor
old the a poor old crested bar/bat has
been chased by a squirrel goodbye
squirrel just go back off to the east to
the Lepidus and her baby it's very much
interesting to see the Lamba taking over
the responsibility of where to go and
what to do these lepers were very much
in rags and a call was heared Columba
decided to go and since then she's
responsible the mothers just following
everywhere mother's just joining her on
what she's doing you can see that the a
cub is so very much interested on play
and the mother is not interested
but this this gives Columba an
opportunity to learn quite a lot of
survival skills when they are playing
they can be able to learn to survive in
the jungle so they can easily adapt with
the environment look at that this is so
beautiful so I just want to see what is
going to happen and what is the
intention of Kalama because she is the
responsible here she's the one who
decided to come this side so I want to
see what is her thought now she is
taking the orders she is following the
mother now Tandi you can see she is not
going down there
Tandi somewhere ahead of here
look at that you can see she's hazel I
did you check I didn't get the question
nicely I hear this about the sounds I'm
not too sure hazel
when it comes to the number of sounds
that cats can be able to analyze at a
time so that one I have got to
investigate and check how they do it but
what I know is that the cats they can
easily analyze and they can hear very
well they can even see very well
now they are hiding you can see they're
getting very much camouflaged so let me
just pull forward and see if we can have
a good sighting
oh there's someone hiding somewhere
somewhere Oh Nadia Paula nothing is
happening at the moment because here it
seems like it's all about playing
colaba just want to have a little bit of
some exercise and I can see the mother
looks very tired not much interested on
playing today
so it is very much quiet here not no
bears nothing no small animals so they
are not hunting they are just playing so
you can see there now the Lamba is is
back again moving towards that side you
can see that Columba is very much
interested in something it's coming back
again Robin that is very true their
senses are very much sharp cats they are
well gifted when it comes to their
senses look at that that is cute
it's looking at this side
as you can hear someone approaching
you can see the ears are moving every
time
so I can see now that she is very much
camouflaged
look at that he's trying to hide away
from trying to hide away from a little
bit of noise so I can see it's now
moving back to the bundes moving back to
the bush Safari South the Lepus I'm not
sure if the tongue comes very rough but
if we can check the females there's
something very interesting about the
tongue they are doing to the cuffs you
will see after birth these females they
lick their little ones and they always
keep licking them when they're still
very young they do that for a reason
when they are licking the little ones is
when they are helping for the blood
circulation and also activate the
skeletal organs the saliva of the mother
also gives the little one lot of vitamin
D so now God disappeared so they are now
all moving back to the thick bushes
yeah now let's see if maybe Jim's my
colleague on the other side got
something I will just now go back and
see if there is any other activities
taking place where the caucus is held
well the activity taking place here is
some eating and some looking by the
Impala since all the viewers do not wish
to look at my face they wish to look at
the animals over here possible faces is
the least most appealing thing on this
game Drive there we go making their way
in the winter varying their diets
now that tree that they're eating
there's gymnast pouria bucks if olya and
gymnast pouria bucks if olya is known
for very very high tannin content and
somehow these Impala are managing to
cope with those talents it's quite a
feat oh it's an impressive feat I mean
those things are so bitter you wouldn't
want to put them in your mouth at all
you may not want to anyway but you
definitely wouldn't like to bite on them
or true them
look at that face isn't it wonderful
look at the detail and the colors so
sweet look at the colors the blacks and
whites and browns well you're looking at
their minimu these animals are more
common here than they are on the Mara
I'm trying to think of another one
I think mammal wise it's probably only
this one well except I mean you don't
get niala they're so niala would be much
more common here I suppose perhaps the
common duiker as well would be more
common per hectare and see many in the
Mara but the others obvious sort of
comparison is the number of Impala that
we have here versus the number of
wildebeest that there are in the Mara
many many hundreds of thousands of
wildebeest and a few hundred thousand
impalas here so I think that would be
yeah probably be the best answer but you
do get some species that occur in one
place and not in the other and so
therefore by default they will occur in
greater numbers where they occur well
largely there are all sorts of reasons
for why and parlour might have black on
their buttocks one is for heat
regulation the other is that if you look
at that those in fact let's do an
experiment since oh please can you put
the thermal camera on the bottom of that
Impala now what we want to see is
whether or not the black stripes are
hotter than the white bits is that we
don't have any zoom on there do we
sensor oh we do thank you very much okay
let's just wait now obviously naturally
we can't see the bottom of an Impala
that's it move away move aside yes okay
so those black spots are warmer than
some of the rest of the Impala they're
not they're not actually they're cooler
I did hear at one stage that because
they're black they reflect more heat in
theory and therefore the ticks would be
attracted to those parts of the body and
then when the Impala flicked its tail it
would flick the tactics off now there
were a number of issues with that theory
that I had firstly of course you know
I've watched an Impala flick its tear
and I've also tried to pick ticks off
myself and I just didn't believe that
they would be able to flick the ticks
off with their tails and now we have
well I think fairly effectively proved
that the hottest part of the knowledge
behind is behind its tail which is
precisely where you would expect to find
ticks so why they have those black
stripes on their bottoms probably has to
do with the following mechanism of some
sort or some sort of camouflage the
default for any guide when asked why has
an animal got a marking on the backside
or was visible from behind is to say
well it must be a following mechanism so
that they can follow each other when
they are running away from predators
that that is not necessarily true it's
just a theory that humans have come up
with so that's one of them the other is
that of course any kind of striping will
break up an outline in a woodland
environment so they're not striped on
their bodies but they are striped behind
and perhaps when they're running away
from their predators that striping helps
slightly to mask where they're running
in wouldn't I think that's probably all
I can say on that particular matter
let's continue
since unless you wish to add anything
mm-hmm yeah you would see would agree
with me with you I thought we were about
to get a pearl of wisdom there
this is wonderful r LC is having a
wonderful afternoon let's go across to
him again oh yes it's been absolutely
awesome folks just relaxing with us and
kuma Pride and and they are very relaxed
with our presence is the odd one it just
puts the Twp and watches us and that as
I say it's just as a result of them not
being too comfortable with those strange
animals that walk on two legs and they
do have a very natural fear of us and
that's actually very good for us because
I wouldn't want these lines not to have
that little bit of cautious nature
towards us otherwise we'd be in trouble
but I can honestly say that this is one
of the sort of based encounters that you
would have if you had to come out to
South Africa and you go on a bush walk
this is the kind of distance that you
can expect you get to Lions as as as a
closest you wouldn't be getting any
closer than this sometimes you can have
a bit of a clearer view of them maybe
they're out on the rocks or you know you
can get a view it may be it can be on an
elevated position or so on but every
situation is different and you always
just take it as you can but in Bush
walks not generally for the best
close-up photos of the big five it's
more to get luck and as always used to
say to my students you're um you're
driving around when you are driving
around in the cameras if you sort of
driving around the animals houses but at
the moment we've gone inside their house
when we go on foot and we're scratching
around at the moment
right inside the Lions bedroom and so we
do need to be a little bit more cautious
when we're doing that because they're
obviously gonna react quite a lot
differently in a personal space so
they they obviously do just watch us a
little bit like that through the bushes
PETA you say that you don't blame them
and from avoiding humans aside to you
well yeah
PETA that every man for himself but yeah
you know animals and humans and and we
can be quite quite nasty creatures and
we as humans that we can also be
absolutely amazing and and so I just
think that if I if I put a cross to them
that I don't mean them any harm and then
they're gonna do the same to me and if I
respect the wild animals well and I and
I always do then I pretty much can't
stand my ground because I don't mean
them any harm and I'm showing them all
the respect they deserve so I would
expect the same back from them and I
think that's a good way to go through
that now taja you wonder you know this
that story has been peddled them you
know for very long time that lines and
and a lot of animals can smell fear I
don't I don't believe that that is true
I think it's more to do with the kind of
body language and a reaction the way
that you react to their presence I think
the animals can very very easily pick up
if you are scared and that does with the
way that you present yourself how do you
react to being around them do you look
like you're scared
and and it's very easy actually to pick
up somebody that looks scared and if the
line moves forward do you back off do
you stand your ground do you get a fart
you know all these kind of things it's
very easy to pick up and when your
senses are as acute as Alliance you can
very easily see an animal's reaction to
your presence and as soon as they get
the upper hand for instance if I were to
get up and band together and come
towards us and we had to jump up and
move off well then obviously that now
that we're scared now everyone I think
we've spent a good amount of time here
with them we're gonna be making our way
out of here and call the vehicles in and
we do that listener of the Giants with a
baby with a woodland Kingfisher not a
woodland key why can I never say it
right the first time rod that is the
brown hooded King Fisher and there is a
squirrel shouting close by and some chin
spotted Bateses having a little bit of a
crosstie and so maybe ten Ghana is close
by that's why we've come down this area
in the meantime let us just observe the
joy of the woodland the brown hooded
Kingfisher looking for insects on the
ground in amongst the done look what is
subtly colored Kingfisher this one the
brown hooded doesn't have quite the
spectacular sort of them bronzes and
pinks and purples of the malachite or
the halcyon blue of the woodland
Kingfisher but it is one of the health
sinking fishes as much bird alarm
calling around here I'm just gonna drive
forward slightly it mister Kingfisher
I'm afraid is going to fly off let's
just look into these thickets and see if
we can't spot what is causing the angst
amongst know Wendy amongst the birds
so we'll just look from side to side see
if we can't find the tell-tale white
belly of 10 Ghana the sleepy male
leopard seems to be very sleepy a lot of
the time these days as does his son got
that in common for sure
I will keep having a look here Sydney
remains with the Queen and her daughter
a ton d is not completely free at the
moment I can see that she is worried
little bit about the hyena in the area
since the little one started displaying
quite a lot of playing activities so now
she decided to then climb a dead branch
and face the direction where the hyena
is is hiding at the moment you can see
every time she is just checking she is
trying to investigate each and every
noise here so she is not happy at the
moment it is not comfortable at all you
see the eyes are very much clear and
sharp these cats can see about seven
times than a human being and apart from
that take irritability is good they've
got a very good hearing
they came here approximately five times
than we do so each and everything Hina
is doing any movement any noise this cat
is going to pick it up look at those
whiskers
so those because they are not they just
for a decoration they've got a very
important responsibility to play when
this cat is going in between the trees
it's using the whisk us to measure the
gaps
after a comment from Robin Tandy is
always on watch yes that is very true
they leopards when having the little
ones is quite a responsibility so even
if they don't watch out chances of
losing the little ones are very much
high hyenas can be very much problematic
and look at that look at how is living
there
this is quite a very beautiful sighting
so there is not track showing me that
this leopard went to the waterhole
earlier on they have been here since
this morning the kata Steinbach and they
have been feeding here they are not that
very much water dependent these cats
they do get quite a lot of moisture from
the food they eat
even h7 the lepers they only meet the
male's during the mating season they
don't get married and stay together for
a long time only during this season of
breeding then they come together and
they split again so the male's they are
not responsible to come and feed the
little ones you know it's more or less
the same as my culture in vendor we we
have got kids but we normally take the
kids away and leave them with their
grandmothers the grandmothers is the
ones that are responsible to grow the
little ones yes we must have to take the
accountability of taking the kids to
school and buy the food but who must
have to spend much time with the kids is
the grayness mother and father they
don't play a very significant role when
growing the little ones we give the
diplomas to the grayness grandmothers
are the ones that are responsible to
take care of the little ones so here
mothers are responsible to take care of
the little ones
it is quite a lovely sighting
I hope neither gonna wake up and go up
to a tree and have a meal in a very
short space look at that that leopard
looks like is completely sleeping so
Mallika yes indeed is quite very much
beautiful when the lipids lipids legs
are just hanging by the branches and the
trees when they're sleeping so the ears
are very much conscious they are
sleeping like that but if anything
happened any break stick they will pick
it up immediately and they will act as
if they were active not laying down they
can be very much fast
that's how cats operate
and may see a Columba at this stage I
don't think Tandy will be able to
instruct a llama to go after a tree
something you must have to remember is
that the little ones sometimes the age
of Columba now is interested on too much
play when this little ones when this a
threat instead of hiding away sometimes
they want to see what's happening so
that's why Tandy is facing that side
because the one who came back to here
where we are first it was Tandy but it
was Columba but Tandy had overtaken
Columba and work in front because Tandy
knows that little ones can they like to
try a llama might try to challenge
anything coming you know how little ones
do things it also happens to the animals
that is why when animals got small
babies the chances of catching prey are
very much low because little ones always
spoil the chance of hunting they expose
the strategies
so the the hyena is still here and is
also lying down flat I can see they just
in the middle of those glasses right
there it doesn't want to give up we
could see duty Kalama is not yet strong
enough to defend herself from the hyena
but as a small one calamba can always
try and check a chance because at this
stage Columba is not aware of the
consequences of provoking other animals
they sign I saw earlier whereby calamba
decided to jump and run away to where we
were earlier when she was playing around
she decided to go and investigate the
sound we had by herself and the mother
was guided by Columba that has shown me
that Kalama doesn't know he doesn't know
yet how it works he doesn't know the
consequences of trying to investigate
what is making noise at this stage is
still very much young to understand that
so you can see that they are not yet
interested on feeding they just about
few meters away from the tree where the
food is
next yes
hundred percent for sure animals are
very much well gifted they can be able
to distinguish between our voices and
other voices that is why some of the
animals if you are giving them problems
once they pick up your voice they change
into an aggressive mode because they
learn to associate the voices together
with how we are treating them some can
even be able to associate our bodies and
every time they pick up the bodies and
they react they retaliate but we're by
the human are not a threat to them they
don't mind it but if there is a
breakdown of the relationship between
human and the animals in those areas is
whereby when they pick up a human voice
they must just think about her to defend
themselves
this is quite a very beautiful pose look
at that
the animals can be very much yeah indeed
this is a gorgeous lovely sighting to me
as well I am falling in love with the
cat see and humor the cats are so very
much beautiful I have been guiding since
2007 and the interaction with cats where
I come from is different
Here I am seeing quite a lot of cats
there I was battling to see heads almost
every day this is lovely
it's an ornament for me to find myself
working for the Juma Game Reserve and
Safari live look at that
yeah now the cat is very much relaxed
I'm just gonna wait and see what is
going to happen but for now we can go to
my other colleagues and see what they
have got around the game reserve Wow
everyone it's often that this happens
when you're busy walking or receiving a
sighting and you can very often find one
of the animals in a much better view
than when you first started and we have
exactly that this time as well now this
female is nicely out in the open this
cut grass between us and her and she is
very relaxed now what I was meaning
Illya or trying to explain is to do with
the body language now and look at this
cat you can see the body language is
that of a complete relaxed animal and
it's not decided that couldn't change in
an instant she could go from that to a
very aggressive animal in a split second
but you see how she's lying down he is
flicking every noun in for the Flies and
sometimes just closing your eyes a
little bit
she's watching nuts but she's not too
concerned and so we obviously in a
comfort zone and if we had to walk
towards her we could obviously get into
a little bit more you know critical now
Ravinder if we wanted to get away from
these lines Oeste confronted us and
maybe came towards us the very important
thing is to stand your ground and if
they had to come aggressively you can
maybe give a bit of a shot at them but
the major thing is to never back off if
a Lions coming towards you
the only time is that you would back off
keeping your face fronted towards them
it would be when they turn around and
move off always they lie down like this
one is doing here but if it's coming
towards you you should not be running
away or even trying to leave the area
you need to stand your ground that is
the most important pot that you need to
always remember
with lions it's like if you pull a piece
of string for a little kid to get if you
turn your head so we won't be doing that
we'll be leaving this area with our
front towards them and my cameraman and
McCain Scott that's facing these cats
but there is absolutely no reason for us
to worry whatsoever so I think we're
gonna head on out nice and slowly
without disturbing him
in the meantime after James
well the update I can give you is that
we didn't find in Ghana but we thinking
we can hear him calling just north of
where husana is so that's very
encouraging he's probably still around
I'm gonna go off to Tandy as well that
simply because I have to record
something for our upcoming TV show of
precisely 30 seconds no longer from a no
shorter and so we're gonna go and do
that I was hoping to do that with asana
but he is so flat so asleep so not doing
anything that I'm gonna go off and do it
with Tandy and tomba but on the way
there we might discover some interesting
creatures which would be quite fun we'll
see what we find on the way it's a
gorgeous afternoon it is a little chilly
I must say this winter has been colder
than I remembered the one before but
that's alright
Rosalind yes we do find giraffes
absolutely from time to time sometimes
there are many sometimes you swear that
they've all forsaken us for no real
reason but we do find them yes and you
know every night that we flown that
thermal drone around the place we have
found giraffes lying down obviously with
their heads up but lying down very
exciting to find them on the drone but
you know if they're in the blocks
there's sometimes quite difficult to see
but we do see them regularly
let's keep going on here you drive at a
relatively good speed because the light
is now so absolutely magnificent that if
we find Tandy and Columba in this light
well we'll get a wonderful promotion
done this is the one of the lowest
points on Juma
no indeed I haven't heard anything about
Anderson mail after the loss of his eye
we don't even know how he lost his eye
of course could have been hind it could
have been the warthog perhaps could have
been our friend Tam bat who swatted him
we haven't heard how he's doing there's
some beautiful mule is there we just
gonna keep going on here for a little
while
the light is magical
and I don't think there's great clouds
of holding any promise of any kind of
rain bull strain and winter is very
unusual here
elephant tracks all over the road which
was nice he had so many the other day
walking through this area we did one
elephant segment on foot and then all
the way home we were walking in between
herds was it scary
it was getting dark but we survived
since I was not with me that day where
you seems don't know
all right I'm going to catch up with you
where you were going now
a ton d still very much relaxed um and
Columba just decided to walk away again
and Kalambo walked away very silently
Tandy couldn't even get any information
about the disappearance of Kalama at
this stage and I'm very quite sure that
now Kalama is about 250 to 300 meters
away from Tandy and this is something I
was talking about earlier that at this
stage the age of Columba she is not yet
too sure about the do's and the don'ts
she is leaving the mother here trying to
defend her against the hyena and now
he's working all the way up 250 300
meters just playing around just by
herself and I think that is a dangerous
exercise because she is jeopardizing her
own safety I can see that now Tandy has
crossed the head a little bit
a safari south the lepers they they have
got to mate for about approximately
three approximately three days
consecutive days and they must have to
do a lot in 15 minutes
so you can see that oh now I can see the
hi nice up there trying to sniff up that
is why now Tandy is checking something
the hyena is up here now trying to pick
up something from the Apotheker so this
these animals can be able to smell
something a dead carcass very far away
approximately four or five kilometers
they can smell a dead carcass that's
quite a very beautiful shot Robin at
this stage is only one hein I have
spotted is not a lot and that Inca they
are still very much safe at the moment
and still a country Columba just got
disappeared like that scenic the
distance between the hyena and this
untundi Here I am talking about less
than 25 meters or less it's not a lot
and 25 meters is not a big distance when
the lepers are irritated they can go
very fast
John I didn't get your question very
well if the FC can give me that question
again John that is true the heinously do
get an unfair application they they
failed repetition you know if there's an
animal I have got to recommend for for
for for real renaming hyena was gonna be
one of them I was gonna recommend that
and because a lot of people they
associate Highness with a lot of bad
things it is quite a very good animal
some they don't like them because they
take away food from others but that is
how there's been designed and some the
associate the hyena with a evil staff
and quite a lot of African tribes as
well they they don't believe in highness
I think ina is not a good animal they
believe I in a brings bad luck
Peter thanks for the question I come
from when the vendor is quite a very big
area because that is the area which is
consisted of all the vendor speaking
people but amongst the the vendor land
that is where I come from this some
other villages my village is very much
big in terms of kilometers I can say
it's about I can say is about 25
kilometers away I can see now when the
sun is shining still focusing there she
doesn't want to reposition what she's
seeing that higher she wants to make
sure that she's seeing what the Heine is
tending to do each and every intention
of the Hina is recorded now indeed is
quite a very beautiful sun shining on
this leopard spot the rosette so each
one of them has got its own stripe
pattern but is not easy to identify them
so now I will be checking any other
development maybe Ralph has got
something interesting on the other side
while we do we've got a fairly relaxed
could you just stop a hit yeah
I just want to see if we can just get
out and get a better view on it again
because it was really so relaxed with us
very close to it which is quite unusual
and it needs to be she needs to be
careful because the vines aren't far
from here so she could quite easily
become dinner then she is just feeding
on in the bushes there but I think if we
actually walk a little bit forward and
onto the road we might get an ask
so it's just walking as I say do not
worries about us at all which is rather
strange maybe because it's a youngster a
little bit more cracking we might get a
clearer view yet he's watching us now
look at those massive second lot dish
years right look at that
Wow just carry on feeding pretty girl
huh I'm actually here chewing as well
you be careful pretty girl because those
Lions will have you for dinner and I do
think that they're gonna hunt to not say
you better make yourself scarce and
don't hid where we were just coming from
I hope you hid in the opposite direction
rather than take out one of those
Buffalo although that's discriminatory
isn't it
I think those lines will take what they
can get and this little kudu here would
definitely be on the menu if it had to
get too close to him or didn't spot them
lying in the grass in the quarry
thickets it can be quite easily become
dinner because she's also just feeding
in the quarries and that's what she'll
do moving on over towards the lions and
if she's not alert and notice him know
very quickly grab it
see necklace kudu I would say is
probably you know eight to twelve months
old it's not very old at all and could
who do grow extremely quickly and I
would definitely say that it's it's not
much older than a year a year of age and
I'm surprised it's not as around maybe
this is some more a little bit further
into the thickets there and what is that
is that a quarry that she's feeding on
look black worried I'm not quite sure
that's a star Apple
it's another tree is obviously I mean
very much leaves there I have to go
closer that I chase it off and I wanna
do that and run here mid-afternoon feet
lovely not now starting to chemistry as
well how do I go she's got one like what
lipstick on she's been eating ice cream
all she's been drinking milk you see the
tail completely down not brown but and
when I get alarmed or they are running
through the bush that tail will almost
flicks right up onto the back and then
it explodes exposes this very white fur
that's underneath and then very much
like a white flag no Reeko yes obviously
right down the line that would be
related to giraffe and zebra but it's
it's very far so this is part of the
antelope and giraffe and zebra obviously
was not in that category these are
related more closely to bush back to
your niala so those are real close
relatives the bush buckin in y'all
that's a little family of these guys
okay so you see that is listening to us
I think we're gonna move off in a
different direction we've got to slowly
start making our way back towards camp
but the sun's starting to hit towards
the horizon so I will do that and I hear
that certainiy has found something else
I am looking for a Columba Kalama good
disappeared and I can promise you now
Kalama is at a distance of approximately
two thousand meters away from the mother
the mothers just left they're not even
aware that Columba decided to move
towards the the Western direct eastern
direction of the reserve and that gap is
too much when Columbia Street and I
don't think Tandy will be able to defend
her so the little one now is just moving
around by herself trying to orientate
yourself which is very much dangerous so
you can see this cat just went past this
fire break and if we can check by the
fair break is not even come off late
it's nice and clear so she can easily
become a target so here by the fire
break it looks very much dry
Linda these animals they they can even
do what is called cannibalism
where predators they they can be able to
kill each other
his chances are very high hyenas will
definitely eat that baby leopard and
it's not stopping
what disappeared just that they did the
cub salamba decided to get disappeared
by the prohibited area I can't go there
unfortunately but I saw where she went
maybe she's gonna come back again here
or the mother got to follow turn turned
eager to follow Columba and see where
she is obviously went and got up there
is going to get very much upset
yeah Isabella what you are saying is
what I'm saying
be careful Columbo I just want to go
backwards forwards and try and see if we
can be able to sport this Columba here
so let me just try to see maybe you're
going to be able to sport Columba here
but it's quite very far I can promise
you the distance between Caramba and the
mother is too risky
let me just try and go further back so
that my operator Camilla figures can be
able to sport from his position as he is
higher up than I am
I'm just gonna try by all means and
sport remember
yeah there's a very big termite mound
which is obstructing the view I can't
see very well on the other side
I am very quite sure that Tandy is not a
way about this distance disappearance of
Columba how tral humble left there I saw
it happening I was unexciting and Tandy
is facing towards the southern side of
the game reserve watching the Heine and
Kalambo was at the back and Columbus
truly left Tandy and created a gap Elia
own they were all together same thing
happened but the mother could be able to
pick up this the noise from the glasses
when Colombo was moving away and then
she just stood up and ran away
in order to get out of calamba but this
time Kalama managed to escape without
the mother knowing what she's doing and
where she's going and that might disturb
Tandy a little bit when it comes to the
mood soon as she speak she picks up the
disappearance of Colombo she's not going
to be very happy and she might not be
happy with everybody now yeah now what
I'm still looking for Columba here these
a guided walk taking place in the park
let's see what Ralph is having at the
moment on the other side Wow everyone
I'm still trying to find the bird that
Craig is spotted for you but he says
it's a white bird scrub Robin and well
there are very pretty little birds and I
do like hopping around in the scrub as
their name suggests and they've got one
of the most variable of all the little
birds calls and you know there's all
sorts and they let me try some of it
they do it
and a very much of a songbird or all the
Robins and that's obviously that's one
of the little things and as I say very
variable and and get the bearded scrub
Robin and the Browns grab Robin so those
three very difficult to tell apart
because they do sing very very nice
little tunes and I'm not hearing him
call at the moment and better very nice
it would have been able to spot one
lovely now barb birds do you have a
sense of smell and they will be able to
pick up different scenes and and and and
they also are able to feel with the
Bulls but there's mommy got little ape
openings on top of the Bulls so they can
pick up different scenes but I
definitely use a lot of this site
especially the die urn all birds a very
very sharp eyesight and it's all to do
with the differences in rods and cones
inside those those eyes but much like
the reptiles the in which they're
basically all reptiles with feathers and
it does make for difficulties in judging
dips so they can see very far but then
struggle to to work out their dips as to
where things are so that's why you often
find birds especially the predatory
birds bobbing their heads and moving it
from side to side and in fact inside
doing triangulating exactly where their
target is so at the moment I'm just
hearing all sorts of little scrubbed
it's calling and you're very often we
have a little alarm call that some of
the birds do and it can be across the
board because it stimulates the other
birds to come in and help them mob a
common enemy and they sometimes did
Shh and if you do that you can sometimes
actually call them in if there's a bit
of a bird party around so we often just
sit and do that and there's one doing it
at the moment I'm wondering if he
spotted something like a snake or a
predatory bird is a few birds just
floating around there and a little bit
of an hour-long call but sometimes they
can also mimic that to get rid of birds
like the chorister Robin will do that if
there's a nice a food source they then
exhibit the sort of alarm call I had to
get rid of the birds so that they can
then feed on all under food all on their
own
so birds can be quite tricky sometimes
and mummy King locked the fork child
Rangga also mimics are very often the
pearl spotted owl at that because that
one attacks other birds and feeds on him
so Mary knows so Lindsay you said that
that's your 200 species of birds on
safari lodge so Lindsay well done good
stuff 200 species that's a good amount
of birds I'm not much of a bird counter
myself but I must say 200 Birds that's
definitely an acolyte so well done
Lindsay and keep it up as we go along
but you can see just in the area where
we are at the moment very very brown
very dry looking everything is grey
brown the grass is all lying over on
itself and the trees all pretty much
leafless at the moment except for the
odd quarry or bush willow lying around a
little bit with the termite mound and
the soil poking through it does
definitely make it as if things are
pretty dead around here but it's
definitely not
Paula after after there's a fire it
would depend on when the next rains come
so when like now they've burnt some of
the fire breaks at the moment and the
grass isn't gonna come through just yet
it's gonna come with the new rains and
it'll probably be around September
period and after that it's literally
within within a week you start to have
the new grass coming through but if it
was burnt in summer obviously it
wouldn't burn as badly because it would
be green so you generally burn it when
it's dry but it does happen sometimes
and then that regress will be pretty
quick and sharp after that so it's all
down to the real summer growths
especially here in the live felt where
I'm from in the Eastern Cape of South
Africa we have a lot more evergreen
trees and a lot of greenness that
continues on through the winter periods
as well right
we're gonna continue on our route
heading back towards camp but I hear
that Andy's still around
Tandi is still around we're having quite
a good time with her here she's perched
perfectly perfectly here on the log and
I'm assuming that Sydney hasn't managed
to find to the Lumbee it we will move
out of here so that he can come back and
enjoy this cat I think in a while in
fact maybe who entered in a way he's
gone anyway we'll find out I do feel a
little unfair that I came in here simply
because my cat happened to be a flatter
cat they would attempt of course to do a
we did attempt to do a little promotion
naturally the script that I wrote took
me about seven days to get through
anyway that's as it be that as it may
we're enjoying her posing perfectly in
the light here
absolutely stunning now Paula that light
really is just quite stunning although
isn't it and she's so completely relaxed
at the moment it's magical
I promise this morning that I was going
to stop using the word magical but I as
yet failed I suppose you'll forgive me
given what we're looking at here
I can't believe how relaxes I haven't
seen her this relaxed around vehicles
for a long time there's another chap in
the siting he drove her right up close
and she didn't even roll and connive it
which is fantastic
and she's fast asleep
it is so interesting also half Columbus
spending more and more time away from
her of course that's totally normal as a
lipid gets to around nine or ten months
old she was going to spend less and less
time with mum that's how they operate
and by a year she could be independent
and he certainly if her brothers you
need to go buy she'll have to be Dundee
of course getting on as it were and it'd
be interesting to see if she does have
another cub
now Robin Lila there's nothing wrong
with a word magical there's quite a lot
wrong though with using it incessantly
like I have been it's become a bit of a
sort of verbal crutch as it were I keep
using it again and again and hopefully I
will find some other sort of adjectives
incredible there's another one that we
all get stuck on from time to time
everything becomes incredible I once
countered The Incredibles in a TV show
review that we did we watched the thing
over the course of two hours and
incredible was used what was it it was a
it was a horse on and there's a husana
and gyeonggido sighting and incredible
was used a total of 64 times in the two
hours by all of the presenters so that
was quite something
Mar 12 2016 5 4 2 can as a gin and tonic
perfect evening
I don't know a child of the universe
it's possible and you know these things
very there's so many variables we act
you have no idea about so she might
become independent to 12 months she
might take 18 months to become
independent I don't know
well that's not a bad shot is it
sindelle how's the two-shot they're not
good not working okay we're going to do
another promo eventually depending on
whether she moves or not well Amy the
picture of the leopard is picture
perfect yes but I'm gonna have to move
the car slightly for my next promo
attempt and face do you mind if we
quickly have a go before the sunset
marvelous okay let's go back across to
Sydney he's somewhere around here I
think looking for Charlie Harbor yeah
Colombo just got disappeared and I am
battling to get hold of Colombo at this
stage however I have got something very
much interesting to talk to you about if
you can look there you can see that the
some grass bent and the area has been
bent not long time ago and some other
people are asking themselves was it a
natural fire or it was man-made
fires we do use them as part of their
management tools in conservation we use
them to create firebreaks so that winter
season towards spring when the rain is
charging sometimes natural fires as a
result of lightning they do okay so this
kind of fire breaks they have apart from
that if there is any kind of accidental
fire so that it doesn't affect the whole
patch we create this kind of fire breaks
so this grass they look dead but they
are not dead I am Telling You
grass is a very much clever because
there are growth points they hide them
at the bottom they are inaccessible even
the grazers is not easy for these
animals that eat grass to be able to
reach the growth point of a grass grass
instead of getting irritated by the
fires they enjoy it so grass is nose
that fires is burning plant old material
and the
new growth is going to come out so on
this grass all of them none of them is
dead come the rainy season you will see
the merry growing again and it's not
going to be the new seeds coming out
very same old grasses are all going to
recover and bring too much nutrients for
these animals to feed
we do need fires in this kind of a
natural environment Cathy the reason to
control the ban is that we don't want
the fire to burn everything for the
animals if we don't control the burn the
grass are so dry at this stage is the
dry season otherwise all the grasses are
going to be wiped away and animals are
not going to have anything to eat so
that is why we have got to control the
bed reason for us to come to do this
fire breaks is to try and be proactive
look at that some of these bears
folktale drama quite a lovely bird is
looking for some kind of insects here by
these burnt areas but it's still getting
because now insects are very exposed
because the area is bent so these are
kind of bears which are getting benefit
from these fire breaks look at that
so that was a folktale drongo
a Pola I am not too sure about the
species that are migrating the most here
in Juma I since I have got here I've got
here just during the dry season after
the birds have already migrated so not
to show about the species of birds that
are migrating the most or that are
carrying in the area the best that I
have met so far here in Juma they are
all common residents I haven't met the
migratory species yet only when they
come back by the rainy season is when
I'm going to familiarize myself with
them so that is not even the fo'c'sle
drone others say the black flycatcher
see the folktale drongo the tail has got
a fork and that one does not have a fox
so I couldn't recognize it properly
during the first sighting yes so the
name says it all a black fly catcher so
it's catching the insects
a Shelly thank you for the comment yes
now the light is getting beautiful the
Sun is now approaching the horizon so I
can see the reflection of the Sun is now
coming to this side so I'm just gonna
reverse a little bit and show you how
beautiful the Sun is getting at the
moment I'm just gonna reverse a little
bit not too much yes I'm going to show
you a very beautiful Sun you can see now
the Sun is approaching the horizon that
is beautiful look at that so you can see
that in Africa we've got a very
beautiful Sun set but also our sunrises
are very much beautiful
you can see the Sun is very much bright
and just before it gets disappears so
soon as the Sun Goes Down Ivy thank you
yes it is quite a pretty picture
lovely so now that picture is going to
serve a purpose soon as that Sun Goes
Down it will be a big call to the
animals that are active during the night
the Nocturnals to come out as I'm
talking to you now the temperature is
starting to get cooler and getting
cooler so when it's getting cooler like
this the animals that are active much
more at night they are now going to pick
up that and it's when their winter
stretch and become active and those that
are active during the day when the Sun
is going down is also saying to them go
and rest
yeah you can have me for a quite a
couple of minutes just to enjoy the Sun
going down in Africa Juma Game Reserve
the western side of Kruger National Park
it is quite amazing to see the Sun going
down a lot of people don't realize that
I am out in the bush every day and I'm
so very much privileged to see the Sun
going down every day and to see the Sun
coming out almost every day
beautiful sunset and the clear skies
when the Sun is going down it goes down
very much quickly so you can see that
the Sun is going is traveling as
rotating at high speed
because when is going down it just going
to take very few seconds is gone so the
Sun looks very much big unbelievable to
see that the Sun is even five million
younger than natural water so the water
was born first before the Sun the water
is just about five million years older
than the Sun
so when this Sun is going down like this
also some of the Bears
just going to start cooling now bears
they've got a very interesting behavior
so now the Sun is about to go down what
I'm going to do now is to see if Ralph
on food has got something otherwise is
going to be very dangerous for Ralph to
walk at night
well everyone as we are making our way
back towards camp we stuff all these
little interesting things and this here
be a goal and G a double L and it's on a
silver cluster leaf and I'm sure that a
lot of the regular viewers or any
regular visitors to South Africa would
have seen these before but it is quite
incredible that this is caused by an
insect and so this is not natural on the
tree well it has been caused naturally
by another organism but not naturally
occurring on the silver cluster leaf
itself or terminalia sericea which is
now pretty much without leaves but this
is actually from a wasp that has come
and stung up the tree so that under
sting animals or us as humans they also
sting plants and what they then injected
with is a growth hormone and it then
creates a little sort of cavity and that
the wasp can then go and nest in and so
very clever from the wasp and I wonder
hardest evolution began and and what
will happen in is it lays its eggs on
the inside and those little lava will
metamorphosis and break the way out as
we can see with that hole there
once they reach adulthood and I will
emerge as wasps and very very
interesting there's all sorts of
different species of these as well and
if you go back you can actually see that
this tree is almost like a Christmas
with decorations from the goal wasps all
over the place here
all these little goals dotting and it's
quite particular for the silver cluster
leaf so I'm not quite sure what the
exact reason for that is and if any of
you do know why
the goal was Sutekh terminalia sericea
or the sulfur cluster leaf in particular
please send those answers to me hashtag
on a safari live on Twitter because I'd
love to know I do know that it's quite a
sort of species specific like we do get
with the fig trees and the fig wasps
each different fig tree has a different
fig wasp and that will go into pollinate
the different fruits but very very
interesting now as it's starting to
towards darkness I don't know if you
guys can hear but it's quite a way off
silent and you can that the hyenas
already waking up and we can hear them
doing the characteristic in just that
front yet I wonder it's gonna be an
interesting evening when a hyena start
calling at that early stages of the
night I wonder if it's because I'm ting
gonna and those cars have got meat stole
up the tree but that's very interesting
indeed so I wonder if they're gonna be
bothering those lipids to not but while
speaking of lipids of tea James what
well here we are everybody we're still
with the Magnificent Tandy we've got
slightly closer to her she this time and
because she seemed so relaxed we did
another little promo attempt which sure
sins or tells me it was relatively
acceptable
he was quite fussy about it actually I
kept doing them a Linda's thinking they
were okay and he'd say no the angles not
quite right please try and get out of
the car in the last one he basically had
me sitting on the log next to her which
was quite effective
their sign of Columba and I'm assuming
Sidney and Fergus didn't manage to find
her anyway she'll be around here
somewhere ones looking very relaxed
isn't calling at all and now the two of
them apparently are heading towards the
lives that's fantastic good idea those
lines could easily get her to stop
hunting which will be fantastic this is
very beautiful indeed Senzo I've not
heard you say that before actually
Marlon is a pretty magic sight I took a
couple of illegal photographs as well of
his body but now the light has gone to
camera let's go away
should we have a quick look at her and
flip I mean you
we own fear young
it will now see the fear picture she's
got a warm nose warmer ears whether she
has a warm heart or not I don't know if
you are new viewer this particular piece
of technology is made by a year and it
is a thermal image basically it's
picking up for the heat signature of the
mammal the mammal in question here is
ton D then you can see precisely why
she's lying on that log look how warm it
is wood does retain the heat quite
nicely after it's been sonned
and obviously that wood has been sand
for a little while now and that's why
she's very comfortably sleeping on it
the temperature will plummet sometime
during the night I again used the term
plummet advisedly because clearly I
realized that my definition of a
plummeting temperature compared with the
definition of the plummeting temperature
if you come from Canada for example
Russia or Iceland for that matter yeah
is really the poor i have no conception
of that sort of level of cold water sins
or I might say since I mean it layers
have we got on so far since I was County
wearing five layers the temperature is
I'm gonna guess when the wind blows
probably about 61 degrees Fahrenheit
sixteen centigrade maybe even warmer
than that have you got something else to
wear as well he's got five with him how
many of you we're encouraging four just
four since I was from a place called
Pietermaritzburg which probably doesn't
even get as cold as this
take care the eyeballs are hot because
they're not insulated that's why so the
rest of her body is insulated by hair
and skin which stops the heat escaping
but her eyeballs are absolutely not I
tell you what might be quite interesting
and I don't believe I'm going to offer
you this opportunity and I don't mean
that to you the viewer I mean that to
Sims or since all is that clear to
zoomed in to focus on my bald head and
be fascinated to know if the top of my
bald head gives off more heat than the
rest of my body is it possible or not it
is possible I can't here we go everybody
you can do an experiment I'm going to
turn this way because I want to see the
experiment okay let's put me into FLIR
am I too close okay all right we'll do
it when we've moved away from the lip
but I'll get off the car and we can show
you know it's not gonna no notice this
is my face okay no here we go everybody
my head looks like the Sun you know get
back to the lipid so there you are
before you see bare skin and bare skin
I'm insulated by hair now it looks like
the Sun you see since or did I look like
a heavenly being there I thought I did I
think we get to do an experiment when it
gets dark and we're going to put you in
front of the car as well because you
have a lot of hair and we'll see if your
head it's any less sound like than mine
I look like Iron Man that's very that's
right yes I can't fly that maybe I can I
just haven't tried
a ton d very very peaceful of course and
why shouldn't she be at Sunday after all
she's not at work all right let's see
how far Sydney's got towards the Lion
prior that Ralph had earlier
yeah I have just left Tandy and Kalama
in that area now I am heading towards
the area where the lounge has been
spotted earlier I just want to try and
see if we can find those lions so now my
plan is the king of the jungle so I
haven't seen anything yet on the road so
but I hope when a good day I'm gonna
find those lions I can't wait to get
there and see if we can find them that
will be a big bonus after a good
sighting of Columba and turning this
afternoon
so now we can go to Ralph
while I'm heading towards the land area
well everyone we sort of we're a a near
to a campus we've now come to quarantine
and sorry I just got a little message in
my ear they saying that we will offer a
but we're not we are live and well we
are in quarantine and we in the last
little time of of lot the Sun has now
well sit and we're just watching as
quite unusually and I'm not gonna be
expecting Craig to follow but once again
we've spotted some bats that are flying
around and I find this very fascinating
because they generally are not around at
this time of year there's not enough
food for them generally and normally and
so for me you know they normally migrate
to the eastern parts near the coast the
forested areas with sidewalk warmer
because of the ocean and then up into
maybe Central Africa then closer to the
equator but these little micro character
ax or the insect eating bats and we do
call another the quite common the little
horseshoe faced bet they actually look
rather strange if you look at them and
close-up but they're tiny little things
and they're floating around all over the
place but really they've just arrived in
the last few days and I wonder what it's
all about so that's really strange
now scenic the bird that I haven't seen
in these parts but I would love to see
is the marina trogon but he really
struggled to find him in these parts of
also more closer to a little bit more
forested areas and where I am from in
the Eastern Cape there's quite a lot of
them there but there's such a beautiful
bird
another one being the gorgeous bush
Shrike but also a little bit more
tropical and that pennant
winged nacho that is one that I always
loved seeing and but at the moment there
won't be in breeding plumage so you
don't see those long streamers coming
off the edge of the wings that really
make them special and you'll see that in
the summer months and you can also call
them when they are around with the
streamers with a very similar call to
thee as sort of territorial call so like
some we're going to now slowly be
wandering back into camp as per usual
once the large fades it's not really
safe for us to be RTR because those
Lions that we are watching earlier
they're quite nervous of us during the
day but once it gets to this time of the
day they turn into a completely
different beast and we don't want to be
around when there happens so we're out
folks
and we'll see you tomorrow yes good
night Ralph may you sleep well captain
pin drop here we have tündi again she's
just decided to shifty a little but that
the warmth of the log makes me want to
go over there and lie on it I must say I
don't think I probably will I think it
would be suicidal as I would like to
because does getting slightly
uncomfortable now she might go from move
she might start calling her daughter
lanique um a very good question why
doesn't the therm will pick up warm
breath I guess there's probably just not
enough of it I suspect that if she
started to breathe very heavily then you
might see streaks of warmth coming out
of her mouth but you know I couldn't
really tell you I just imagine that the
density of what she's exhaling is
probably not sufficient to actually
create a heat signature for the
sophistication of camera that we have or
the camera of the level of
sophistication that we have
oh dear queen look how pretty you are
well I would quite like that too
Michelle I'd love to see Columba coming
to mummy
so that you could rest in peace well
she's around she's very independent
doesn't like to hang around love too
much she's just hitting that teenage
phase when it's not that cool to be
around mum all the time but she's not
quite independent enough not to depend
on mums food and safety she provides
well certainly would not be too afraid
of tündi was my mother she is not a cat
to be trifled with she's just listening
to some alarm calls of some Franklin see
how she's looked towards them exactly
like we might
he's obviously better at assessing
whether their potential threat than we
are that's the direction of the high
hyena went orphan maybe the Franco lino
saw shouting at the Franklin at the
hyena gracious one too many mornings
waking up at 3 o'clock
that said that you will feel sorry for
me everybody that's why I said that
Betty you're looking at her there just
like a Queen Elizabeth is just about the
oldest person in Britain so Tandy is the
oldest Lippitt on jhummer more now she's
not on talking rubbish sorry tink honest
older than her turn-ons we think we
don't actually know when taganas
birthday is but he is probably a body
year older than she is well yeah maybe
they're roughly the same age
he was in theory now you know what I
think that's true we think he was born
beginning of 2006 he actually wasn't you
know he'll be somewhere between 12 and
13 now she's potentially going to live
much longer than he has because she's a
female and the females do tend to live 2
or 3 years younger than the male longer
than the males
alrighty now let's see what she does I'm
not gonna move yet this of course is the
tree that she had her little killed in
earlier this evening this evening this
morning we found her here and what time
but quarter past four we came up here
and here she was looking up into the
tree islands he left there and this
she's hung just the head yeah I'm gonna
move slightly and then we'll get a bit
of view if she does do a tree do you
hear that Wendy just started born
straight off combin if she's gonna go up
the tree
there is a bit of Steinbach lifts up she
goes oh sorry about that sins oh it's
cars and Stratos to the end of stress
we're gonna get a lovely sizing no we'll
just pop around the side here see what
we can see from there and then what we
are going to do is as it gets dark is
we're going to move out of the sighting
so that if clam bar does come back we're
not here in the darkness we don't want
to be here in the darkness but the paths
while when they're adult it doesn't make
much of a difference it's just not great
when there's meat to be here when there
are their youngsters around there's a
big log in my way excuse me
it's not the best views it's Enzo I mean
that's her bottom really let's try this
see if she turns around if she doesn't
turn around everybody I will go back the
other side shall we go into infrared
faith will do I pass it infrared Oh
beautiful wilden's Enzo he antistick yes
I think that I've parked you all I
apologize in the worst possible time the
horizon is still too bright for us to
give any contrast on the cat that is a
back end no meanwhile it's a relatively
attractive back end it is not a most
attractive part so as we move from here
and try and get a better picture let's
go to Sydney and see highs lion
expedition is going
I have already started doing my trekking
and I have been lucky so far I did money
to pick up a very fresh lie on track you
can see on the ground there so the
chances of seeing the lions are very
much high tonight so now without
interest of time I am going to follow
the tracks before it gets very dark
[Music]
they are very much fresh tracks
so the I'm convinced that we might find
him
I didn't get the name of the viewer but
what I can tell you is that cricket at
this stage they are not available they
are hiding they will come back during
the summer season is very much quite at
the moment
very very much quiet
so the tricks I saw are hidden the
tracks I have seen they are heading
towards this direction I just want to
try and go around here and see if we can
find something
concider the dung beetles are one of the
very most interesting insects and then
the dung beetles they help us a lot
without having the dung beetles South
Africa is a country which is a country
where I come from was going to
experience a very serious problem when
it comes to the population of flies when
the dung beetles are destroying the
droppings creating balls is when they
are destroying a place for the Flies to
lay more eggs in other words they help
to me meaner to minimise the population
of flies and after that the dung beetles
they they roll the ball and dig the
ground in order to bury the ball digging
the hole increases the space within the
soil for water penetration and after
that they are going to bury the ball
under the ground now they are going to
act as a natural fertiliser so you can
see that that insects is very small in
size but has got a quite significant
role in order to prepare the soil for
the seed germination so now I'm just
gonna try to radio in and hear if there
is anything happening by the Lions
because I can see now Lions in front
here they are walking some are coming
towards my direction we have managed to
win the battle here comes the it's quite
a number of lions I'm not too sure how
many this is lovely
look at that look at the tip of the tail
nice and black look at the the colour
behind the ears the tips nice and black
considerating listening to what is
happening in the area
Michelle Wow yes this is a very much
magnificent sighting look at that
so lions are my favorite kids
Waveland yes true indeed lions are
amazing look at that how they are
walking they are walking as if they
don't like look at the muscles you can
see that those mothers has been designed
for hunting purposes so now I'm just
gonna move for a bit and see if we can
have a good good sighting
so now we can we can go to a James and
see what China is doing on the other
side while I'm trying to find a better
visual we've got two absolutely gorgeous
pictures here I'm not sure which one you
are I'm assuming you're on the infrared
one I love the contrast of that black
and white picture really I don't know it
does something profound for me so we'll
zoom in on the cat and as we do that
we'll merge into the sort of will pink
figure of tandy eating hestian book it's
almost disturbing watching the crunching
in this that is golden Oh eyes looking
at us hello also you can see the warmth
from the steelbook not because it's
making heat of its own because obviously
it's long dead but because of the saliva
of the predator chewing on the meat some
are slightly less disturbing watching it
in FLIR than it is in glorious
Technicolor watching the poor antelope
be chewed into very small fragments like
I say we're not going to stay here for
long those will be our last segment with
tandy but there's just such a precious
picture this
and there's something about this
particular camera that we're using that
does a glorious job of creating a
black-and-white picture with the
infrared we use two kinds of cameras and
I think this one does a better job at
this particular thing
it's utterly hopeless and many other
things but it does a really good job
with this one not much left to that Stan
Walker I seriously doubt they'll be here
tomorrow morning it's not impossible
that they would be just sort of resting
up here
I always think it must be so nice to be
a leopard with a kill because the relief
of having something to eat for four days
of not having to go off and struggle and
try and find some food especially if
you're a mother like this one must be so
nice to have a pantry in the tree that
you know no hyena can get at and
obviously these wild and almost don't
think like that I don't think I'm sure
she doesn't necessarily feel a sense of
relief but she certainly looked relieved
and relaxed as she lay on that log
valise crunching sound is going to
attract the sharper eared animals out
here which is basically everything so it
could easily attract hyenas and may well
attract Salameh back to the tree she
will be hungry probably but as I was
saying this morning she most certainly
is still always is giving kills is
giving kills brain really is a adult
she's making kills of her own small ones
I'm sure gerbils scrub hares maybe Birds
Mongoose to nice piece of meat there
it's not quite making me hungry though I
must say
since I'll just make you hungry or do
you just feel slightly nauseated but you
don't have you're not feeling hungry is
that because you ate a box of eat some
more biscuits before we left
oh no you didn't you let me tell you
what I when I got on the car today
everybody sins all had a plate in his
hand was on a car going to work sort of
kitchen and in their plate was the funny
sense of what was in the plate it was
bread and raisin bread and ice cream and
what else and yogurt raisin bread ice
cream and yogurt is what sins will head
for for lunch today there's no wonder
he's not hungry when you watch just
handy eating
all right everyone we're gonna leave
this kitty because we want to give an
opportunity for salamba to come back if
she can
in the meantime Sydney I believe has
another view of the warm-up ride
I've got the UN Coahoma pride here they
are all walking on the road it's quite a
number of them you can see the the
slowly walking down some of them in the
bushes so it's quite a lovely sight and
you can see now they are becoming active
daytime is suitable for them to walk
around now so now we are going to go
onto the infrared you can see now they
are nice and and clear there this is
quite a big pride I love lions look at
them how they work is interesting it's
like they're bored it's like they're
bored
a Deborah the koomer pride is a lovely
pride look at that along the road they
just everywhere this is lovely
I'm just gonna try and move forward a
little bit and see if I can have a
better visual again
so they're not working very fast they
are all working very slow they are very
much relaxed so I'm not gonna lose this
writing
trusty I'm going to count them now for
you I will tell you just now just give
me a little bit of minutes I will tell
you how many I'm seeing but it's quite a
lot at the moment let me see one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
if I'm seeing nicely I think they are 11
or 12 they 11 or 12 together
this is beautiful
so they are not showing any intention
all they're doing is just walking
Sina I have experienced Leon hunt on
several occasion and recently few days
ago here in Duma I saw the telematics
the telematic ride nearly caught a
buffalo in front of me they are very
much interesting when hunting lions look
at that on a convoy this is beautiful
this is quite a lovely sighting
look at this yes everywhere on the road
all you see is just lie of lions
everywhere this is exciting
hey it is very beautiful a this is very
much interesting you can see one coming
to join from the side alley I didn't get
the question very nicely if FC you can
give me that question again I am not too
sure Ali I am not sure if she's here but
she is part of this pride so I'm still
building a little bit with the
recognition of some of the individual
amongst this prize and different
correlations in the reserve so now I'm
just going to move on and see them nice
and closer again
that's a lovely command giraffe girl
Okuma a traffic jam you can see the
traffic is not moving because of them
and they are so lovely
[Laughter]
different V was as good different views
on this pride Paula is saying the Lions
are like a flowing river of lions that
is that is what I'm seeing
I am still here enjoying the last moment
of the pride going down on the road
they're just everywhere is quite a
lovely animal now they are letting some
of them on lying on the road one is
lying on the road looking at the others
going down look at that
so today has been a very great afternoon
quite a lot of cats activities it was
lovely
punctuated with a beautiful sunset
leopard and lion during the same Drive
thank you very very much for all your
comments and all your questions we will
meet again tomorrow
at half past six